thanks for your concern
let's start this rodeo can't just yet
not till you get in the range
go on set up chop chop
all righty how many we got just six
goddamn well no point crying about it
rules are simple right there's the
target shoot it
don't matter which one go on and shoot
your neighbors most hits wins
uh meaning hits on the target not your
neighbor
oh right uh small caliber iron only
don't go
showing off with your [ __ ] assault
bangers or no rocket pukers got me
first prize is a pistol but uh
a real nice one it's [ __ ] nice i'm
telling you
anyway uh enough words
[ __ ] up ready
three two hey hey the hell is that
the hell you doing with that double
barrel it's a small caliber
only uh forgot my iron
must be in my other jacket and that's
where you keep your gun in a holster
a holster get the [ __ ] out of my sight
now
[ __ ] chum chill i'm going
i'm going pearls before swine for [ __ ]
[Music]
sake
all right three two
one
[Music]
target it's a target not the wall
looking good rudy go go go
halfway there b get it [ __ ] for [ __ ]
sake
the hell is that lisa get your glasses
[Music]
15 seconds last chance me
stop everyone stop we're done
first place rudy and second
lisa rest of you hacks are a disgrace
for crying out loud sorry v
i thought you'd cream the competition
but guess you're not as sharp as i
thought
clearly having an off day know the
feeling
been having a bad day for a decade now
contests didn't do [ __ ]
didn't sell a goddamn thing nothing
should try not call them potential
buyers
bush league but
[ __ ] i got something you got to respect
you don't know how to shoot don't do it
take care of me
[Music]
[Music]
you